we've been waiting and waiting to do
this story to get the latest information
but we're just not getting any better
information to reset Monday night there
was a Democratic caucus in Iowa after
getting one or two percent of the vote
the vote stopped coming in
irregularities quality control a crashed
app on Tuesday we got 62 percent of the
vote by Wednesday we had 71 percent of
the vote by Thursday we had 97 percent
of the vote and then all of a sudden the
DNC says we want to start over we want
to recanvass all of the results so I'll
just give you the numbers I have right
now as of right now pete Budaj edge is
ahead by 0.1 percent of the vote and by
three state delegate equivalents this
will work out in the end no matter who
ends up winning this is going to work
out roughly to the same number of
pledged delegates for Bernie Sanders and
for Pete Budaj
unless the numbers that we have so far
are just completely wrong there are
numerous questions about this but as
always the real story is that we knew
from the start with proportional
apportionment of delegates the leaders
likely the frontrunners we thought it
would be Biden and Bernie it ended up
being booted judge and Bernie they're
going to have roughly the same number of
pledged delegates and this is going to
be a fight for way longer than Iowa this
is about momentum and claiming victory
many relevant questions from the Iowa
caucus does it make sense for Iowa to
keep going first the answer is no dealt
with that on yesterday's show is our
entire system of primaries and caucuses
broken very much so we dealt with that
on yesterday's show is the DNC in
shambles and in an embarrassing
situation yes we dealt with that on the
Wednesday show but then now the latest
news is that Democratic National
Committee Chair Tom Perez came out and
said we need to recanvass all of the
results because now there are questions
about accuracy even of what's been
announced so far to recanvass is
essentially to double check the vote
hand auditing Iowa election officials
would have to hand audit the caucus
worksheets and the
reporting forms to make sure at every
level the votes translated correctly to
the caucus worksheets to the reporting
forms and so on this is another reason
why we should just have a primary to
start not a caucus and arguably we
should get rid of caucuses altogether
it's insanity and within a few days
we're gonna be on to New Hampshire the
reality all along was that whether Pete
or Bernie win in Iowa by one or by two
or by 3 or by 5 percentage points it's
not going to make a difference to the
long term math and it's more about this
being another one of these endemic
unfortunate realities in the political
machinations machinations machinations
of the DNC and of corporate politics and
of the establishment efforts to
influence this election so before you
know it we're gonna be talking about New
Hampshire results Bernie and Pete
essentially tied will likely come out of
this with the same number of pledged
delegates if not varying by maybe one
delegate it's an embarrassment but
that's where we are as of right now let
me know what you expect in terms of
shenanigans between now and the DNC I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman do you feel like
you just don't have enough time to
become as intellectually well-rounded as
you would like to be that they're just
not enough hours in your week for you to
read all of the books that you want to
read one of our sponsors is called
blinka stand it's an app that lets you
consume an entire nonfiction book in 15
minutes it's only about eight bucks a
month but you can try it for free for a
week and get 25% off a subscription when
you go to blankest comm slash Pakman
what blinka studs is take thousands of
popular nonfiction books and condense
them into either text or audio that you
can read or listen to in just 15 minutes
and what you get is all of the most
important ideas and information from the
book imagine being able to listen to an
entire nonfiction book in the amount of
time it takes you to drive or walk home
from work I just finished listening to
catch and kill by Ronan Farrow super
interesting book probably already
familiar to some in my audience and a
really interesting take at how Harvey
Weinstein and his alleged transgressions
were brought to light excellent
investigative piece Blinky's has totally
transformed how I consume information I
love it of course I read a book in its
entirety when I can but there are simply
just so many books that I want to read
and would not have the time for if it
weren't for blinka stay they have books
on politics economics philosophy science
you name it you can try it out yourself
totally free for a week and get 25% off
if you decide to subscribe just by going
to blink as comm slash Pakman I've put
the link right underneath this video
like the rest of us I bet you're going
into 2020 thinking about what you didn't
get around to in 2019 and your goals for
the new year
if you want to work towards being your
best self in 2020 understand more about
the world around you and make sure that
your time is well spent then blink astiz
for you